dans la plaine céréalière du loiret
voici à coup un bourg situé à une
quarantaine de kilomètres d'orléans le
genre de communes que certains urbain
qualifie parfois de blade de troupeaux
mais combien est là qu on a appris
qu'une sécurité
je pense que les mentalités ont changé
un peu au niveau des grandes villes vont
s'apercevoir qu'en fait la campagne
c'est pas si mal que ça ça fait plaisir
de voir le monde rural qui commence à se
réunir comme avant parmi le gros millier
d'habitants il y à quelques agriculteurs
dont marc gaudet le président du conseil
départemental pour qui ces quelques
heures au grand air sur son exploitation
représente une sorte de récréation
j'ai bien conscience que quand on est
agriculteur ou quand on vit à la
campagne dans une maison un peu isolée
on a la chance et je mesure bien de
pouvoir sortir autour de la maison de
pouvoir et quand on est agriculteur de
pouvoir être dans les champs en plein
air pour pouvoir la caisse d occupation
ça je mesure bien que le confinement à
la campagne n'est pas du tout le même
qu'en ville néanmoins le confinement est
bel et bien respecté justement parce que
chacun ou presque dispose d'un espace de
liberté à la maison ou à proximité
immédiate
et puis la solidarité facilite aussi le
quotidien des élus j'ai fait appel aussi
en donnant un petit message qui a été
mis dans toutes les boîtes aux lettres à
toute la population pour me signaler
s'il y avait des populations fragiles
s'il y avait des situations délicates
donc j'en ai rencontré deux cons à gérer
et je pense que tout le monde joue le
jeu toute la population pas seulement
les aigus les ans skull fuscien le nom
des habitants des coûts sont même
unanimes sur un souhait particulier que
l'ambiance locale perdure après la crise